engine sequence start has been it's rare
that two rockets are readied
simultaneously on launch pads half a
world apart aiming for the same Target
both were headed to the International
Space Station the first was Russian
sending a passenger ship to replace
another that Russia says had been hit by
a small meteor and leaked all of its
coolant
second was American carrying a mixed
crew from the U.S Russia and the UAE
that could only arrive once the rescue
ship was in place stage one throttle up
Russia and the U.S run the International
Space Station together with Europe and
other partners
the war in Ukraine through the global
space industry into disarray missions
dependent on Russia were canceled or
postponed and Private Industry looked
for new launch options
but America's NASA and Russia's Ross
Cosmos struck a deal in the summer of
2022 that despite sanctions they would
barter seats carrying one of the other's
astronauts on every launch and promising
to evacuate the others in case of
emergency
sometimes people think that we can like
you know split Spain season there is no
way it's like it's like cutting your car
in half you know one half and the other
half will not work
misfires and Strikes have jostled the
station over the past two years when
debris are incoming astronauts have
limited options the station can move or
a crew can shelter for safety there are
no built-in Escape pods Crews have only
what they came up in
on board science experiments continue in
robotics the human body in space cancer
research and physics the real output of
the space station is maintaining this
immense complex engineering Miracle uh
for decades
and we need to know how to do that if
we're going to have you know settlements
on mars or or deep space
human systems and that depends on the
people inside
cooperation has a long history the life
of people in space at the International
Space Station is really setting a very
good example of how people should be
living on Earth
all of this just a month before the
release of the first feature film shot
in Orbit on the station by a director
and actress from Russia
about a fictional Health Emergency in
space
Colin Baker Al Jazeera